[موسيقى]
التتبعات القضائيه التي تمت
ضدهم لم تكن بسبب انتماء اتهم الحزبيه او
بسبب ارائهم او موقفهم هي تمت يعني بسبب
افعال
نص عليها القانون الجزائري وعلي اتحال من
الناحيه القانونيه وبوصف عميد المحامين
اقول وان كل انسان بريء الى ان تثبت
ادانتهم خلال محاكمه فيها حقوق الدفاع وما
دامت القضيه او القضايا امام التحقيق
فهناك مبدا وهو وجوب احترام سريه التحقيق
واترك المساله للقضاء ليقول كلمته في
الموضوع
[موسيقى]
تحقيقات يعني كل
يعني شخص محالمه من التحقيق له لجنه دفاع
وله كم هائل من المحامين بالساده المحامين
الذين
يساندونه وينظرون على امام هذه الدواء
وبطبيعه الحال يعني حتى القرارات التي
يتخذها الحاكم التحقيق او قضاه التحقيق
ممكن تعن فيها امام المحكمه الاعلى درجه
وكذلك ربما حتى المحكمه هي تحت رقابه
محكمه التعقيب وبالتالي اعتقد ان الضمانات
القانونيه متوفره
والمفيد وانه عندما يقع عرض المحكمه
القضيه امام القضاء في سوره قرار التتبع
ستكون
المحاكمه علنيه وسيدلي كل طرف يعني بدلوه
سواء النيابه العموميه باعتبار مسؤوله عن
الادعاء او المحامون هم المسؤولون على
الدفاع والكلمه هي
للمحكمه التي يجب علي ان تتحمل مسؤوليتها
كامله في اصدار احكام عاديه
[موسيقى]